we started we had two programs for
education one was like summer camp
for kids
and we've been able to see very close oh
wow you say those kids are so brilliant
that we were doing you know getting
farming and technology and those kids
were so brilliant
and then we focus into sort of master
for young entrepreneurs
and getting them very practical to get
them involved you know to do uh to
practice
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with leomi tech
sponsored by hippo insurance opposed
labs touring hillel at stanford leap and
in media partnership with ctec welcome
to 20 minute leaders i am in italy and
this is going to be an amazing episode
meet maurizio rossi
pioneering the startup business and
venture capital in italy maurizio is
co-founder of h-farm having incubated
and invested in over 140 companies the
organization went public in 2015 and was
expanded to an education hub of 51
hectares for 3 000 students in his
previous experiences maurizio worked in
the luxury and sporting goods industries
some involving acquisitions by global
leaders such as lvmh fashion holding and
other major sports brands if in the past
mauricio managed to distinguish himself
in the world of sports as a champion in
offshore racing today maurizio is
committed to running after his four
children and more than 350 startupers
mauricio rossi welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you doing
i'm doing good what about you what
cameron italy welcome to italy i am in
the art and luxury offices and you were
so kind to invite me and we're going to
be talking
with with the supreme director here
and we're going to have a lot of fun in
these 20 minutes because i'm gonna i'm
100 positive
your life is so incredible going over
your journey i had to take a few deep
breaths because you did so much and and
you understand so much about the
ecosystem here
working on a lot of different industries
but most notably and recently age farm
51 hectares of land
that are supporting entrepreneurship
innovation investments education and so
before we get to dive into those
different things mauricio go back and
and tell me a little bit about yourself
and and tell me maybe a few key moments
in your life
that maybe define a little bit who you
are just for perspective yeah
um
yeah that's an interesting question
because it's uh
when i go back you know i think in my
life that uh i
have been inspired
in learning by people
so when i was really about 20
i decided to not follow the traditional
curriculum and study
because i found it was boring
since when i was younger
i was always fascinated by the
other people
so
i decided at some point to become a
shoot captain
ship captain
but i never intended to go into a ship
because i just did like that at the same
time i started to walk
and i had
been lucky
that my family had a business
and they throw me into the market with
that business and i went to japan
japan to set up a sales force
organization for our luxury
company none the company salesforce a
sales force sales forces easier company
their company is being funded by my
granddad i think it was like 80 years
ago wow so in
in a luxury high end this company today
belongs to lvmh collaborate luxury
economy
so
i've been so
in comfort zone
staying with people older than me i was
like 20 and were people with 40 50 35
years old you know and and they became
an oddly genius oh it's
you really
learn the real things
so to me that was the point from where
everything that started
because when i
thought to come back and they say i
don't want to go back
take a bus and go into a classroom
i can read the book
and i can take some teachers if i need
something but if i know the teachers i
get friend of the teachers they can tell
me the things
so i decided to learn by doing and and
my people from the street that was my
main decision and finally i became a
captain
and so i'm also captain
and and i started my my
i decided to become entrepreneur
and pretty soon
i
moved most of my time out of the family
business that i kept a position into our
group i served my family group up to
for about 15 years as a executive i
president
the group expanded in different sectors
and one sector has been developed by
myself it was into the action sport
industry that in the 90s it was booming
in california
there was a bunch of brands most popular
brands i can remind no fear of some of
those brands
has been distributed outside the u.s
through my organization
mainly in europe not just in europe also
and europe at that age was pre-internet
was not eu it was really complex
so for 15 years up to early 2000 2002
that was my life it was between the
action sport
and the luxury industry and they learned
two very important things were you
passionate about those two things so i'm
always passionate things i'm doing
so it's about the doing
i learned two very relevant things on
that the from luxury i did learn
the value of intangibles
any luxury item
it's as a quality
and the quality
it's even higher value
for
the intangible and and the influence in
the mindset
and that was a very important learning
because this chair compared with this
other one might value three times
and the part of the value is because
this is able to inspire you
inspire your imagination and that's a
luxury the actual sport it already 90s i
learned the value of communities and
culture
because that was like the surf the skate
the street culture it was a culture
gathering a community of youth
so at some point
in 2005 with a friend of mine ricardo
donado we decided to get launching this
age farm like create a context where
people
could live
based on some philosophy inspired by
some intangibles build a community to do
something in a place so the the meaning
of each farm is very simple
the brand is represented the driving
force and the philosophy of everything
because age stands for human so
human-centric project and you get the
technology er design around the u1 i'm
very firm convinced about that
and the farm was basically the farm
house of the first generation of the
21st century
yeah entrepreneurs
so we started with a farm and there was
actually one farm house literally a farm
literally a farm house we took it
and instead of having animals and
typical farm equipment
we had entrepreneurs wow and the first
two companies you know it's 2005 we've
been like pioneering in europe so
the most viewable model we had at that
time it was similar to an incubator but
i think
we did launch the first startup studio
venture studio because it was not really
an incubator we were like building
things
and the first five
startups it was in that mode
eighty percent equity owned by us wow we
were taking in residence a sort of
entrepreneur
because this startup you know that was
just about silicon valley right it was
you know it's youtube wasn't there yet
right and google took off or amazon took
off in 2001 2000 it was just really
facebook was in beta so tell me a little
bit about these entrepreneurs that are
coming in how do you
how do they experience h farm what what
do you learn
about entrepreneurship and about your
interaction with them and and spoiler
then it went on to not just be five
entrepreneurs it would be a hundred more
than 140 companies that were involved
with each farm right but that's just a
part right that's just a part because it
forms a journey yeah it's a journey
because starting that in a
grass field
in italy outside of venice and not in
palo alto
it was
really something crazy
at least 10 years ahead of time yeah
and entrepreneurs were not there in
knocking the door or get a deal flow so
the beginning we
because we
are entrepreneurs
we felt to build company
then a few years later we started to get
some sort of deal flow so go in 2007
2008 you know more buzz
and we started to receive enough to say
that the problem of the it was not much
of entrepreneurs because i think italy
is very brilliant entrepreneurs
as everywhere
but the problem was more the luck
to have
a team of technologists
to jump into a startup right so to find
developers because when you are on seed
stage
you basically have a group who co-found
the startup yeah
and that's uh three four people that
take the risk to become entrepreneur
right so another company was a hiring
for developers so that was sort of
challenging to have
the group with the right developers and
then once we found some good developers
the challenge and the biggest challenge
still today it's more on the capital
resources
because it was hard to find the seed at
in the early 2000s the scene was below
half a million wow
much below it was 100k 200k
once us was
over one million for the precede yeah so
it'll always be big difference right but
then if you go now for a seed in in
israel or you will see that five six
million six minutes five six million is
hard to get still today in
not all europe but italy for sure
in at the scale
okay
take me back again to the beginning of
age farm
you're doing a few different businesses
you're involved with yachts and
boats.com and the family and
what why why create this new incubation
for startups what was it about what what
led you to really because the world is
changing for us it was very clear
that the
new millennium the new century
and the internet technology opened a
completely new door
it was very clear we already i remember
we really thought we were thinking about
the mobile
prior smartphone
and we couldn't
build anything like that of course
because we
could not have access to those
technology but in terms of thinking and
modeling and envisioning
that the smart data the cell phone
it could
he could become at some point the
smartphone to do anything from payments
to to the whole business this is 2005.
yes before the iphone yes of course
we envisioned that but we say someone
who do that we knew that we could make
it because
it
would be not an r d center
yeah and not maybe some entrepreneurs
could come and look the door says i want
to build a smartphone but you know the
sort of smartphone the original is out
of israel and then it has been developed
in the
us you know
there are hubs that you can do certain
things on others so part of our
revolution came out from this experience
and so walk me through a little bit
with the journey of age from you're
you're so you're at the scene you're in
the incubation phase you have five
startups and that point how big is h
farm in terms of even land just for
context
the kpis of each farms is like you have
now is those three thousand plus
students coming 25 000 visitors coming
those 140 start of it was one period
before jumping to the ipo because we had
few pivots so
from the let's say incubator we decided
to move them into adventure accelerator
so to have a direct investment arm right
at the same time have the chance to
create a cohort a batch of entrepreneurs
right
but still the problem it was to get the
funding to catch up with the funding and
with the full-on funding so
what we did in 2011 we started to invite
all accelerator in the world
and we invented we created the game the
global accelerator meetings that became
later into the global accelerator
network again that it exists it's
gathering something about over 100
accelerators today
and we are co-founder of that
but still in 2011
we said we need to position ourselves to
become unique for something we are in
italy
and what is the ecosystem in europe and
ecosystem in europe is more probably
about the transformation
than become
the
uh let's say disruptor
because out of our 140 startup we've
been
lucky
and proud
to also
start a unicorn
because recently there was a startup
called depop that has been acquired by
etsy for 1.6 billion yeah and that
company has been conceived and has been
developing for 12 months in each farm
and then we understood that that company
was the right one
and we've been able to approach venture
capital from london
and they
took it to london and the company
started a completely new
second stage and third stage and the
company became successful
and that
reinforced us the convention to create
and pivoting somehow and reverse
engineer
the knowledge
to deal with entrepreneurs
to redesign the open innovation process
for corporations
because europe is about
a multitude of diverse industries
all consolidated
all they need to transforming somehow
right most of them will have a negative
impact by the disruption
because you cannot escape from that just
a great example comes from the
automotive industry and tesla
you don't want to react
and the tesla it's just coming up yeah
so
you cannot avoid this one
but you cannot base europe in a
disruption because at some point you can
start catching up and do new things
and become more awareness one of the
problem is the pundit that this pandemic
it's increasing the awareness around the
europe that you need to change right but
the driving force my opinion is the
generation shift
into the 21st century
because the 21st century is bringing few
elements
uh internet
new challenges
like the esg and
the real globalization yeah and the
generation which is not just
digital or tech native the millennials
and the z gen the alpha gen that will
soon jump here
but that's a generation which is born
into this new context right so from your
age and the younger you're much more
sensitive
with the disparity with the eight
billion people that has to leave the
same context than my generation but this
these are the values that you brought
into h exactly humans that's everything
it's around there so 16 years ago so yes
that was the point and they took
different shapes according with the
evolution of the market right because we
are a private company for profit
so
and because of our position it was very
difficult to access to still today the
venture capital industry in italy is
very small
the community is very small right
and the entrepreneurs are brilliant so
some of them need to migrate some of
them finally are able to attract
resources from abroad so we are german
investors coming to invest here in italy
but that's you know still on a small
scale compared with the quality of
entrepreneurs so just briefly the whole
education aspect you're mentioning that
by 2020 you're going to have
3 000 students in k-12 on age from
campuses not just k to 12 because we we
start from k to 12 but we go up to the
university because we have universities
free we free programs with university
and masters
and nh farm yes of course so what is
that and so is that connected at all to
the entrepreneurial and yes
it's it's a part of an english we in
2009 we started with two programs for
education one was like summer camp
for kids
and we've been able to see very close oh
wow you say those kids are so brilliant
that we were doing you know getting
uh farming and technology and those kids
were so brilliant
and then we focus into sort of master
for young entrepreneurs
and getting them very practical to get
them involved you know to do uh to
practice
and to be very close with the start of
what it means to become entrepreneurs so
the the the the shift point was 2015
once we decided to
list the company in the stock market
so we had to change the business model
because the inequity equity-based
business model based on startup could
not be listed
so we took the transformations and the
open innovation for corporations and
strategized the company to deal with the
with that with the new technologies as a
business dream
service based
so it's a business that today
it's about 50 million euro wow
it grew from zero in five years wow and
then to have the education in this
education at this point can become an
element where can identify over the
future age form and become a unique
element so
we started this progress to get this
bull
pivot
to do that we had to increase
the facility right because the facility
was just basically the 30
and the 30 percent it was
maybe half of our business because today
each pharma runs 800 employment 100
people are employed unbelievable on 51
hectares
which is unfavorable so we have offices
also here in milan and we have a team
for artificial intelligence is in turin
so it's it's not all the 800 there but
it's a it's a it's a different place
wow at the pivot and the direction it
become more intense and i would say over
the future
by 2024
that's at this uh conclusion of this
next plan
it will become purely educational
and try to move the this
to instill the culture of
entrepreneurship from very young
and then
growing start acting as an entrepreneur
and addressing cohort from school so
it's nothing different than maybe staff
for harvard is doing or other
universities but we start from the
business
and from very own yeah it's a mine so
coming from the business we we know what
the business is looking for and we went
to the education
those universities start from the
education they know that at some point
they need to go to the business right i
think the uni
the uniqueness for each farm is exactly
this one because team printing the
personality
is real entrepreneurial because people
are entrepreneurs i mean what you
mentioned before about the about my
generation and younger about being very
impact driven and and being very
cognizant and intentional with the
things that we work on i'm seeing a lot
of my friends from stanford from 8200
asking those questions before they join
a company what are we doing why are we
doing it how is this going to impact the
world and this impact mindset in the
context of entrepreneurship already from
the bottom layers of the education
system and obviously then hopefully to
invest also in those in those startups i
think that's amazing tomorrow so i have
dozens more questions to ask you and but
i want to go back a little bit about you
and i have three last questions and i
want to go back to your childhood what
really fascinated you as a kid what were
you doing to become an uggle
to become an adult
that's why that's why i took that
decision
that's if they had to think they were to
say because i could do things that i
couldn't do because of a baby because i
have the older restrictions you say how
hell can i do that but i cannot i need
to become an adult the faster the best
answer i got so far
what what inspires you today as you go
about your day today yeah you're no
longer the ceo of age farm
no i'm retired from the holding company
as my monday it was terminated with the
2020.
and
i
am close to each farm especially with my
heritage as a co-founder of this one and
um
what inspiring me it's today
it's still
this big shift it's very fascinating
because those challenges are bringing
greater new opportunities
and
the pandemic which is just a sign of how
the world is changing and we just show
and we lived and we suffered the bad
side of this situation
right but the
there is an opposite side that is
opening solutions and i think that's the
first global challenge
that humanity is facing that we should
think in a in a global way and that's
something which is inspiring me because
i'm curious you know
and that's to say there is many things
which is coming up because
you die to reborn
and this cycle always happen
and uh that's uh really the 21st century
and the global scale we can see now what
is really the global scale so that's
fascinating might be that's inspiring so
i don't know it's practice what to do i
still have no idea of that but the
setting would i love it and what are
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
oh my god
uh creative i love creativity
uh inspired i need to be inspired i
don't want to do anything that doesn't
inspire me
that's uh that's uh that's that's a
problem for me
uh the third thing it's uh
it's a fun
it's a try to help me find this this is
all connected it's all connected it is
stuff because it could be one it could
be three four five depends which one but
that's basically it's to to enjoy
something
right to give you some sort of
motivation i'll i'll add a fourth one of
the visionary that's just what i from
what i'm gathering from this
conversation and i just have to put in
context we're talking about you know a
lot of the our conversation was about
age farm and we're talking about 2005
and we're going back to a time where you
know this ecosystem not just globally
but it's also in europe it's not as
developed and coming in
and having that vision and executing on
that vision and having it grow over you
know i guess 16 years by now having a
growth to the skill that it has and the
impact that it has and where it's going
to go i think it's i think it's
inspiring for me and and it's really you
know the good things there it's uh ash
farm is about a lot of people right
800 people so no no but that's
there's really a lot of people
right it's the result of a lot of people
that
converge in some values
and then they say
some everyone everyone took such a broad
standing so
amazing that was interesting mauricion
thank you very very much my pleasure
[Music]